Brasilia, el país es políticamente
polarizado
se segregó Paraná y es y Lula oscuro solo
en él congreso prometí unirme a la a a
Brasilia sufre de sustos a kilómetros de
seguidores como uno por estafarlo cuando
incluido el sector arraigado en la guerra si
todos con nosotros en este lugar
santo todo para todos y
a todo terrorismo que pretendía Oi
y en terrorismo el fascismo eso es lo que
estar mirando alrededor porque
presupuesta o no inhibida azulada porque la
ser algo muy
importante que ella es inteligencia
investigar todos los orcassos aquí en
financia Dom siendo las armas estas
importante
hay polarización
A qué se parece
dormir
esto es un poco artificial porque no es
quién es realmente fascista si los apostadores
revolucionario
de Lula de PT
queriendo aparecer
noticias falsas noticias falsas y esas cosas
entonces me pareces que cuando lula
gobirner
para agregar ese equipo y obtener un
recuperación económica y estará listo
por qué
ya va a evolucionar hay politicas
de distribución de 80 porque lograron
derecho reforma constitucional que permite
el precio del cráneo
ya intente
marinero pero luego para enviar cuando
esta cosa
es eso
me parece que lavinia esta lista
y si ahi en mi calle
quien abrazó
porque yo estaba en la mala situacion y creo
en lo que estaba viendo cuando la situación de la
merhur
ni siquiera coquetearon con bolsonaro asi que tu
me parece que en la mejora o en la minoria
Peri Grosso y sigue este en Brasil
eder importante
sobre por las miradas a mí ella allí
polarización del gran yo era Cirilo
en los últimos años bajará mucho
tanto por allá
estilo
es concejal y no hay forma de que no pueda serlo
¿Por qué también son minorías?
por favor dale el diccionario que son hermanos
por ejemplo
Si este texto es un tema que siempre he sido
cuando Lula era presidente
primera vez también fue un tema como
imba na septar quemar quemar pasar
Lula le da pulsos a un general retirado
Ministerio que pertenecía a esta guardia Así que
estarás un momento allí con el
militares para ídolos
que han ocupado desde que temieron la antermina de
bolsonaro empeoró después como
bolsonaro operado
muchos ministerios
multiplina soy profesora
Ay, qué
disminuir la presencia militar y nuestra
epitágora que los militares dieron opinión
política cada momento como este año en
situación
lacesto dura como mucho como tu yo
parece que no será un problema
seriamente para disminuir
para cambiar líderes de Los militares
por otro calentamiento más democrático
y bruno
porque cuando Lula era presidente
unas militares que se casaron con ella toda
autoritarias desaparecieron por ejemplo
entonces usted
los pases en el ejército crecieron dentro de ella
Fuerzas Armadas